lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la idea de sacar la derivada de
una función exponencial ya hemos visto
que la derivada con respecto a x de la
función a la equis es lo mismo que ella
misma es lo mismo que a la x lo cual es
una cosa muy increíble una de las tantas
cosas que hacen es bastante especial
piensen que cuando tengan una
exponencial con esta base como en la
derivada es esto mismo la pendiente en
cualquier punto es igual al valor de esa
misma función pero ahora vamos a empezar
a analizar la derivada cuando tengamos
otras bases de alguna manera queremos
encontrar cuál es la derivada con
respecto a x y ahora me voy a tomar a am
elevado a la x donde puede ser cualquier
nombre
hay alguna manera de encontrar esto y
tal vez podamos obtenerla utilizando
nuestro conocimiento de que la derivada
con respecto a x de ea la x es ea la x
habrá forma de utilizar un poco de
álgebra y propiedades de los exponentes
para volver a escribir esta expresión
pero que en lugar de tener como base a
am tengamos una expresión con base
bien aquí lo importante va a ser
recordar que podemos ver
cómo
elevado a logaritmo natural de am ahora
si esto no es obvio para ustedes de
verdad quiero que lo piensen un poco
porque déjame ponerlo aquí cuál es el
logaritmo natural de a el logaritmo
natural de amd es la potencia que
necesitas para elevar a m y obtener a
entonces siguiendo esta lógica aquí
tienes a es igual a un elevado al
logaritmo natural de amd es decir aquí
tengo a ha elevado a la potencia a la
que tengo que elevar a para obtener am y
es por eso que obtenemos aa así que en
verdad piensa un poco en esto no
solamente quiero que lo aceptes como un
hecho de fem debería tener sentido para
ti y es que esto sale realmente de la
definición básica de logaritmos y ahora
sí ya podemos sustituir a am con toda
esta expresión de aquí si es lo mismo
que el elevado al logaritmo natural de
am entonces esto va a ser igual a la
derivada con respecto a x
elevado a su vez a la potencia logaritmo
natural de amd ya esto hay que elevarlo
a la potencia x
y ahora usando una de las propiedades de
los exponentes esto va a ser igual a am
recuerdan si elevamos algo a un
exponente y luego elevamos todo eso a
otro exponente eso es lo mismo que
elevar nuestra base original al producto
de esos dos exponentes entonces esto va
a ser lo mismo que la derivada con
respecto a x de m elevado a la potencia
logaritmo natural de am y esto por x
y ahora podemos usar la regla de la
cadena para evaluar esta derivada
entonces lo que haremos será primero
sacar la derivada de la función de
afuera es decir en elevado al logaritmo
natural de a por x con respecto a la
función de adentro que es el logaritmo
natural de am por x entonces esto va a
ser igual pues ha elevado a logaritmo
natural de a por x elevado a logaritmo
natural de a por x y luego sacaremos la
derivada de la función de adentro con
respecto a x y tal vez de manera
inmediata no te saltes que el lugar es
natural de am sea solamente un número
pero lo es observa porque si la derivada
de 3x es simplemente 3
entonces la derivada del logaritmo
natural de amp por x solo va a ser el
lugar y no natural de am es solamente un
número
así que multiplicaremos a todo esto por
el logaritmo natural de a entonces esto
nos va a dar el logaritmo natural de amd
que multiplica ha elevado el logaritmo
natural de a por equis pero lo voy a
escribir haciendo lo voy a escribir como
el logaritmo natural de amd por el
elevado al logaritmo natural de amd y
todo esto elevado a la equis y es que
ahora quiero que recuerdes que todo esto
que tenemos aquí es simplemente ha
elevado a la equis entonces esto de aquí
se va a reducir a el logaritmo natural
de amd que multiplica a amd elevado a la
equis lo cual es un resultado bastante
estupendo entonces si estás sacando la
derivada de la x eso será solamente a la
equis pero ahora sabemos que si estás
sacando la derivada de ha elevado a la
equis esto va a ser simplemente el
logaritmo natural de amd que multiplica
a la x y ahora podemos usar este
resultado para sacar las derivadas de
este tipo de expresiones con bases
diferentes a él así que hagamos un
ejemplo imagínate que queremos encontrar
la derivada con respecto a x
8 por 3 elevado a la equis a que será
esto bueno pues esto va a ser igual a 8
por la derivada de 3 elevado la equis
pero si nos basamos en lo que acabamos
de obtener esto va a ser igual al
logaritmo natural de nuestra base es
decir el logaritmo natural de 3 que
multiplica a 3 elevado a la x entonces
esto va a ser igual a 8 por el logaritmo
natural de 3 y todo esto está
multiplicando a 3 elevado a la equis